hey everybody is Jessie and I am
streaming from home today and if you you
saw the two other times where I tried to
stream from home you know that the
quality is not good so I adjusted my
settings a lot I don't expect the
quality to be good but hopefully the the
buffering is a little bit better so I'm
also today I'm gonna try to keep this a
little bit short and I'm gonna do some
things that are less code intensive and
there'll be more visual feedback you
know on the actual website and that
should be a little bit easier to see
with the decreased quality so normally
you know I would do this from my office
unfortunately my actually it looks like
I'm seeing from watch at the volume is
really low as well so let me see if I
can do anything about that
so my employer has blocked all access to
github which which I I mean I really
can't I can't work very well without
that so I'm gonna try to do a stream
here I'm hoping that by next week we get
access again otherwise I just I will
I'll be working from home a lot so I can
access github I won't have a lot of I
[Music]
don't know I won't have a lot of time in
the office to be able to stream so off
to figure something out maybe I can
definitely do pre-recorded videos I see
I'm working on the more
on the volume now I'm not sure what the
problem is
okay I found it now is that better at
all the volume whoa wait a second for a
response here yeah look so I got some
questions why would they block github so
see you guys have heard the like the
Petya ransomware thing that's going on
it's not really ransomware I guess
they're saying now it just is a wiper so
okay so better not yeah actually in in
my sound setting so in OBS that's like
streaming software the sound settings
were fine but in the actual settings for
my Mac somehow the input volume for the
microphone got turned almost completely
down and I'm not sure that happened I
don't remember doing that but but that
happened that actually makes sense cuz
yesterday I was doing a Skype meeting
with this this laptop and they were
having trouble hearing people talking so
that's probably the reason but anyway so
someone in the IT department is on a
listserv and someone on that list serv
emailed out to everybody that they had
actually seen this virus this Pecha or
not patchy or whatever they're calling
it now they'd seen it when it first got
started to do its work and they noticed
that they downloaded something from
github and that was the only message
right so based on that they shut down
github luckily one of my co-workers
alerted me to that on Wednesday so I
didn't even bother coming in that's why
I didn't do a stream on Wednesday
yesterday it
they had reactivated they unblocked it
so I could get access to it so yesterday
it was actually be able to go in the
office but then I had during my normal
streams
I had a really long meeting and then
even earlier on I had some meetings or
anything today so my whole day was taken
up so I couldn't do a stream like I
wanted to stream yesterday but I just
didn't had enough time so then I went
into work today and the first thing I
always do is try to do a good pool and
it wouldn't work and so then I tried to
do try to go on github and it wouldn't
work so I called over to the IT
department and they had in fact blocked
github again and when I asked how long
it would be they said oh not that long
and I I said well we're we talking like
days and they said yeah hopefully just
days so evidently they're waiting for
their antivirus software to come out
with an update that protects them
against this ransomware and when that
update comes out then they will unblock
github so that's the story so I'm I
really this really stinks because I have
a lot of work to do and I also want to
stream I haven't streamed that much
lately this week and I miss it I miss
all you guys
and girls and so hopefully this all gets
resolved and I can get back to my normal
streaming and you don't have to suffer
through this terrible quality video
stream unless unless I can find
somewhere else that has a better
internet that I could go to to work then
maybe but I there's not really any like
work places um I live in a small city so
there's just not really a good place
that that's great Wi-Fi that I can go to
work but if I can find one I will
hopefully it won't come to that and I
can just go into the office and do it so
anyway okay I see everybody in the lab
chat now hey hey everyone
so I have a lot of avenues so the we are
gonna go over some CSS changes today I
thought that would just be simple given
the bad quality of the stream it'll be
way easier to see what's going on
but I just want to give you an overview
the site's gonna be undergoing some
major changes in some parts of it so I'm
gonna give you a quick overview of
what's going to happen I'm gonna try to
stream as much of it as I can and also
I'd like your input on some things I
will say I probably only have maybe I
think until July around July 19th I need
to be pulled off of this project and go
to another project so everything that's
gonna happen needs to happen by July
15th so in addition to what we're
already working on before the the
biggest thing that I was working on that
needs to happen is I need to get all the
content of the entire site to be
editable from WordPress so I need to be
able to pull in all that content either
in one API call or figure out how to
make multiple API calls with next j/s
and how they do their server-side
rendering so but that's maybe I'll do a
video about that so I have some ideas
hopefully I'll get to that so here's
what's gonna change I'm just gonna go
through really quickly the change is the
most major changes the the really long
meeting that I had yesterday was all
about changes that need to happen to
this site so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna make this whole section
smaller so this was pretty like our hero
section but it's it's gonna become more
of just a really big nav basically so
this is going to shrink up a bit this
will get smaller this text here will get
smaller this text and this logo will get
larger now I'm not sure about the size
of this logo if I can even make it
larger without it getting pixelated so I
have to check I think I might be like at
the upper end of the range here so we'll
see maybe maybe I can get a better
quality
image that I could make bigger so and
this is all based I got a ton of
feedback from several different people
that are in this department this
catechetical Institute department so I
can't really these are pretty much set
since I it wasn't really my call for a
lot of this stuff although I did have my
input a lot of this is kind of set so we
can't can't really change it the other
thing that needs to change is this bar
here needs to get a little taller and
this text needs to be a larger font size
and maybe even a heavier font weight
we'll see how that looks now this is big
this looks terrible now because just the
where the video was stopped at I was
playing the video I guess it'll low
quality but basically let me do a
refresh just so you can see what the
thumbnail is for this video
there's your gonna be a full screen
video section so this will be a lot
smaller so you'll be able to see like
half of this and you're gonna scroll
down and this is a full screen video I
don't know if we stick with the YouTube
embed or if I'll actually pull in the
video but it's gonna be clicked to play
I'm not gonna autoplay it but this is a
video introduction from the head of the
cata catechol Institute that's who the
sites for does like a voiceover so the
we have a videographer and my department
is pretty really good and he put this
together so we're gonna put this here
this section which I had added is is not
gonna be included after we had to talk
more about what the goals of the website
are which we should have known this from
the outset but I think it just took a
while for everyone to get really figure
out what they wanted this website to do
so we moved the mission statement down
here instead of it having its own
section the quote that was here is
actually mentioned in the video so it'll
still get in there
this section here this formation section
is going to be moved up above
it'll be video the formation section
with the four cards and then the mission
below it and then below that we'll have
announcements like we still we have here
and then we're going to add a contact
form and then just our normal footer so
the home page is undergoing very
significant changes there are the about
page is going to have some links to some
informational pages so there I'm just
gonna have to change it a little bit to
include a section there that can display
links so I'm not no no use in actually
checking the page out at this point the
let me let me check the chat real quick
in case someone had some comments on
this okay okay I can see I did have some
comments about the whole like github
being being blocked thing Grayson says I
can see from a security perspective it
makes sense it does get in the way of
workflow but I don't want data loss yeah
I don't know that IT realizes how much I
use github and the one other person that
does this kind of work in my department
uses github because IT doesn't use
github they use some really old form of
version control it's like a proprietary
system I forget what it's called like
they were using visual source visual
sourcesafe or something and now they're
using like some vault thing I don't
really know but for them it wasn't a big
deal to blocky because they never use it
so yeah I still think the best thing for
them to do would be to make sure that
all their stuff has the the upgrade for
the SMB v1 which is from what I
understand what that viruses is using to
do to get in and actually infect
everything it seems to me from what I've
read if if you have that installed then
you should be fine but
see okay
Emanuele asked why not just make it a
wordpress theme and I just I know we've
got over this before but I keep getting
that question and the reason the reason
basically is this is using react right
now it's late it's too late in the game
to change it to WordPress theme anyway
but there is some advantages to doing it
this way as opposed to traditional
WordPress theme and I'm actually I don't
think I'm not gonna go through it all
cuz I know I've done it in past videos
but I'll let some people in the live
chat fil fill you in on the the
advantages but basically at this point
it's just there's no way I could convert
this into a wordpress theme fast enough
for when I need to have this all done
let's see okay John Hanson says it could
convert the the logo that's a PNG into
an SVG and says it works great fairly
click to do all right awesome I hadn't
even thought of that but that is a great
idea so I'll give that if I need to I'll
give that a try I do prefer to use SVG's
whenever I can anyway Sebastian says
well chrome and Cooper ski decided that
YouTube was not secure yeah I don't yeah
Scott's
giving some some other options for what
source control they use TFS IBM's
subversion it's not subversion it might
be TFS I don't know I guess it does it
doesn't matter really but I it's
not it's not the IBM lemon and it's not
subversion they did use like the old
Microsoft one and that's like not
supported anymore
but they've I'm pretty sure they've
switched off of that one under this new
one so anyway they'll continue on the
the only other section that is getting
major changes is the resource section
also the events section the the
geolocation stuff is now live and I do
want to thank Patrick because he
submitted two pool requests that were
kind of in relation to that section let
me see I wonder if he's on I just want
to bring up the contributor section here
just to give credit to everyone who's
been contributing so here we go so
thanks let's zoom in on that a bit I
know the quality's bads hopefully you
can see that but here's everyone who's
contributed this so far and I really
really appreciate all your contributions
they've made this so much better than it
would have been and I've learned so much
from going through your code that you
submitted and I've already I was working
on just some some little side projects
some fun projects when I was on vacation
and I was going back to your pool
requests that you all submitted and
figuring out how everything was done so
that I could do it that way on my newer
projects so really awesome I really
appreciate that let me go my resource is
working there we go so the right now the
resources section is not it's not
working exactly as expected the the idea
was that it would be it would look kind
of like Pinterest right but Pinterest
has images for everything and as you can
see there's only one image right now the
problem is a lot of the images for these
were just way too small and look tear
when they were actually in here so the
layout for this is going to completely
change so just briefly these will
probably stay here and the search will
stay here somewhere in the middle and
the search might get smaller maybe
somewhere in the middle there's just
going to be a toggle between free and
paid resources so it's just gonna toggle
back and forth I may or may not even
keep an icon that denotes whether
something's free or paid because we'll
just have the toggle I'll see I
basically there's probably not going to
be a view that includes both free and
paid resources together so it may not
even be necessary to have this icon
we're gonna have a drop down here that
has a ton of categories the the example
given that I am so basically the people
who are in charge of the this Institute
that I'm doing a website for they want
it to be like Amazon okay so basically
in the next like two weeks maybe three
weeks I'm gonna try to turn this into
the Amazon as closely as I can and now I
I'm definitely not going to try to
recreate everything that Amazon does but
I'm basically gonna make it so that a
user could come in here they could pick
a category then so they could choose
whether they want free or paid then
choose a category and then choose
whether they want audio or text and then
search within that so you can filter
downs like to a very small set of things
that you want so that's that's how the
filtering is gonna work and then for the
UI these cards are gonna go away and
it's gonna look more like a list so I
know there's like material design lists
let me see let me see if I can show you
an example of what it's going to look
like there at least in my head what I
think it's gonna look like so I just did
some sketches on paper during the
meeting just so that I remembered but
yes it's basically gonna look kind of
have this
list kind of look where I'm trying this
fine if there's a a better example down
farther okay so this is I guess a decent
example where it's gonna be more like a
list of one column list
there'll be images on this side title
the description will actually be hidden
by default but you can click to read
more so it will enable them that to make
really long descriptions if they want
them and it won't mess up the flow of
the page and cause a lot of scrolling so
there'll be a little little arrow to
drop down in the description or hide the
description and then there'll be just
some other basic information about each
resource so that'll require a little bit
on the wordpress end of things to add
the custom fields for that but then on
the UI side of things it'll be you know
we'll be changing that significantly
probably making a new new react
component for that so that's it those
are the major changes that are gonna
happen there there are some other things
that are gonna happen but they're not
it's not really worth talking about it's
a lot of a lot more you know kind of
minor things so today what I wanted to
work on was doing all the changes that I
talked about for this section so
I'm just gonna check the live chat
quickly
yeah Philip was responding is someone
had asked about why not just do it as a
wordpress theme and Philip responded and
said speed easier load balancing I think
not using PHP yeah there's some there
are so many reasons there maybe isn't
like one reason that's like for sure you
should go this way but there were so
many small reasons when you add them all
up it made sense for me to do it like
this
and yeah not having to do a lot of PHP
template things was a big plus for me
because I'm not nothing there's nothing
wrong with PHP that's just not where I
want to go with my career in my learning
path so I wanted I want to go more with
JavaScript and react and I think it'll
be easier in the future given the growth
of reacts someone to maintain this site
if I could just say hey this is just an
HTML CSS JavaScript site basically with
react someone could step right in if
they had knowledge of JavaScript and
probably pick up enough of react that
they could do it I don't I don't need to
say in a job description let's say for
somebody who might replace me one day
and say you have to know PHP alright I
don't need that so anyway but there's a
lot of a lot of reasons not to say
there's nothing wrong with WordPress
temporal site is just a regular
WordPress site with wordpress templates
octavian says it's too boring to stay
longer it's used to everybody see see
Davian I'm sure Octavian is not here
anymore but if parts of the video are
super boring to any of you let me know
what parts are boring and then I will
try to just cut those out I don't mind
if a parts really useful and boring
that's okay but if it's boring and it's
not useful to anybody then yeah I just
want to cut it out so yeah if anybody
else thinks he's boring before you leave
please let me know what exactly is the
boring part XDS which project is that it
is it's the the CI react oh yeah so
github.com / fu s - marcom / CI - react
the link is in the description for the
video
this branch is called let me let me give
you the branch name so you could it's
called home - alt so I'm working on that
branch right now if you want to check
out any of the code all right okay Ahmed
says the user interface design looks
totally stunning to me awesome so thank
you I'm glad you think that yeah so I
mean you all that have been watching for
a while like we worked really hard on
this I really really appreciate you
saying that
XD says would be cool to take it out of
WordPress yeah I've thought about like
totally not having WordPress involved at
all but it just wasn't like going with a
completely different content management
system I the time frame that I had for
this I just knew I wouldn't be able to
do that in this time frame but if there
is a system that would be more
lightweight and still as user-friendly
as WordPress in terms of someone with no
experience being able to come in and
input data then I definitely be open to
that
specifically I would love it if there
was something that was well tested and
reliable that could run off of node and
then that way I could totally cut out
the need for any PHP knowledge and it
would just be JavaScript you know across
the board it bucha asks just to confirm
the site is built with next day s yes it
is it is built with next J s Muhammad
says nothing is boring Jessie you're
doing great yeah honestly if someone's
really advanced at this my videos
probably would be somewhat boring
because I mean they'd already know all
this so unless they're here to help me
out it's you know it's gonna be gonna be
pretty boring so anyway
as long as people are still watching
this and they still appreciate what I'm
doing I'm still gonna do it it does
I mean if it's morning to some people
that's fine they're like millions of
videos out there that they could watch
that may be less boring to them okay
XD says put some configuration
instructions in the readme yeah I
definitely should I've thought that
before but it's just always been really
low on the list initially because I
didn't think anybody would be working on
it but now that you all are helping with
it that that's gonna move higher up on
my list of things to do John's John says
lol boring this is supposed to be your
regular day is an aspiring developer I
want to know when it's boring valuable
info
besides I watch this walk oh so no
problems okay cool yeah that is true I
mean it is supposed to be my regular day
and sometimes things are boring so I
guess that's the point of the video then
if my day is boring then the video ends
up being boring I try to pick the most
interesting thing of the day that I will
be working on to record but there it's
not always fun stuff alright so I'm
gonna go Philip says thumbs down for
Drupal and Joomla yeah I agree I've used
them both before as well I I don't of
Drupal Joomla and WordPress WordPress to
me by far is the easier one to use they
actually the partner site to this so
this is the site that's more like the
marketing site and just informational
and then there's gonna be a learning
management system that is actually built
on Drupal that's not ready yet but it
should be ready by the 15th of July and
when it is then I'm gonna link to it
from there that site is built with
Drupal the good thing is I guess because
we're just basically pulling in
everything through an API if I needed to
pull in data from the learning
management system they could just expose
all that data through an API in Drupal I
guess and I could pull that data into
and then I wouldn't actually have to
anything for drupal so but it's nobody
they actually hired an outside company
to do that so i'm not directly involved
in any of that work all right so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna come back to the live
chat but I want to work on some of this
this section first I don't think it's
gonna take a long time so I'll do some
work for I don't like ten or fifteen
minutes on this and I'll check back in
with the live chat hopefully we can get
this to a point where it's it looks it's
decently you know kind of what we want
and then I'll answer all your questions
and everything a live chat if you can't
stick around till the end of the video
to get your question answered please put
it in the comments or direct message me
on Twitter and then I will I'll answer
your question whenever I get a chance
within the next few days or so alright
so first thing let's just work on so
these are three different components
actually so this I think it's three I
think this is a nav component this is
the hero section and then this is the
stickeen F so we'll be working on all
three of those components it is possible
that I made this one component I can't
even remember when I did that but we'll
find out here so this is the hero
component and let me know if I need to
blow this up even bigger I did preview
the video and the quality was not great
so I'm gonna try to be as descriptive as
I can you know as I'm talking about this
so that you can if you can't see the
code you can at least get an idea of
what's going on there
so yeah this hero section yeah that so I
think that is two separate components
so we're doing we're gonna drop the text
size the font size of this so right now
it's a hundred pixels and let's drop
this down let's just drop it down to 75
for now and then I actually I want to
increase the padding at the top a bit so
I'll make this one 75 set of 150 and
what because what I want to do okay
great
that'll allow me to move this make this
bigger and this bigger that should move
down a bit and then this will look but
that's a decent a decent size will move
this up a bit yeah I like that
that should work for now sometimes it
just works out well you just guess and
it it looks all right let's see margin I
could do this in dev tools too but these
these adjustments are pretty
straightforward so I want to make the
margin negative eighty three let's move
it up let's try to make it negative 100
there we go okay I moved it up a bit
actually I think I want it up even more
I want to see how much I can get this up
here without it okay that's that's much
better there it's it's a little bit too
much right now but we're gonna shrink
this a bit too so I think this will work
by moving this up so we've actually
shrunk this section now by over a
hundred pixels and it still looks you
know pretty close to what it was before
so looking at it now though we probably
need to bump this down a bit more if
we're gonna make this bigger
so let's just let's do that we're going
to bump this down a bit more and we're
gonna shrink this and then then I'm good
to move on to some of these other
components I think that's that's a good
start
so yeah let me move this make the
padding for this one 200 and if that I'm
gonna go this real quickly in case
someone's not familiar with react and
what's going on here so this is a react
component and then within this component
we have what looks like basic HTML and
this is just a JavaScript class it's a
react is is mostly just regular
JavaScript with a little bit of this JSX
is what lets us make the have the HTML
kind of mixed in with the javascript and
it works and that I mean that's just
like syntactic sugar but really what's
going on here is all just it's all just
functions and classes and things it's
basic JavaScript stuff so when we want
to add a style to something we we
actually put in a JavaScript object and
that's how we can put inline CSS into
our our JSX which is what this is called
this this kind of mix of HTML and
JavaScript ok so this works like normal
normally you do have to put class name
there's an NPM module now installed
where I don't have to use class name I
can use class but if you're just working
on react like for the first time and
it's just straight-up react you have to
put class name instead of class okay so
anything that's a reserved word in
JavaScript you can't use so class name
is one instead of using four you have to
use HTML for those two I know there's
probably other ones but for sure those
two you have to change but otherwise you
just make an object so the first bracket
tells basically the compiler that's
going to change the JSX into something
that browsers can handle it's just
tells it like hey we're gonna do some
JavaScript now and then the second
bracket is our objects and then we put
in the CSS and then we make a camel case
instead of hyphenated like normal CSS
and then you know we just add in
whatever we want our values to be here
and these are in you know in quotation
marks and then we just close out our
object and we close out our JavaScript
and now we're right back into the HTML
style if you want to do more than one
since it's a JavaScript object you just
put a comma and then you keep on going
and you make more okay you could put a
bunch of CSS okay now that's one way to
do it there's another way and this is
styled JSX
I don't think this comes with react I
think this comes built in with next so
if you're using next Jas this will work
if you're using just plain react I'm I
can't guarantee that this will work but
you use a style tag but then you just
add JSX in here you drop into JavaScript
right with our bracket and then we put a
template literal we start a template
little this is a es6 thing template
literal syntax it lets you basically
make a string in JavaScript and then you
can put in JavaScript within that string
and you can also have your string take
up multiple lines and it still works so
very very handy but within that then you
just do regular CSS I mean all this CSS
is exactly how you would do it in a
normal CSS file then you just close out
the template literal with your little
back tick and I there's no way you all
can probably see that back to on the
screen so sorry about that I'll try to
make it a bit bigger and then you close
out your JavaScript with another bracket
okay and that's how you do CSS in a
react component these aren't the only
ways there are a lot of other like
modules like NPM modules and things out
there that you can download to help you
do CSS in in your react component these
are the ways that I've used
and then I'm working with now I've seen
like talks on a lot of other different
ways so there may be better ways out
there I'm gonna look
those are big explanations so I'm just
gonna check really quick in the chat to
see if I lost anybody you've had and
anyone had any questions I don't want to
lose especially the people that are
really new to react I want to make sure
that I can help you kind of know what's
going on as much as I can okay I'm not
seeing looks like it looks like there's
not any questions specifically about
this in the live chat right now so I'm
going to move on okay so next thing is
we want to make this a bit smaller so I
do have let's see for the hero section I
have a minimum height set of 80 okay
yeah I think I can drop that down I
don't think I wanted to take up that
much now we'll drop that down to 60 but
then we're also gonna drop our
background size down it's a 60 to match
that we may have to change the
positioning here we'll see also the
margin we'll just we'll see how that how
that works out whoa okay I don't think I
want it I don't know that I wanted that
small I'm not sure what do you what do
you all think in this case I do have
some some discretion here we didn't
decide on exactly how small this section
would get so I wasn't planning on it
being this small but now that I see it I
think it could be I mean obviously we'll
have to position this differently and
shrink this up a bit too but I think it
could be this one work let me know what
you think
I'm for now I think I'm gonna move this
over a little bit and I'm gonna shrink
this text up a bit and just see how it
looks
sorry if you hear anything in the
background those are probably my kids
and my wife shush in them so sorry about
that but in case you missed the
beginning I am working from home today
also let me know how the the video
quality is I expected to not be that
good and I'm sorry about that but let me
know if it's like totally tear
completely terrible like not worth
continuing the video or anything like
that I don't really think I can do
anything about it I've set the settings
you know pretty low if I'd be going to
lower the video is gonna be like really
low quality
I just don't it the screen won't be the
text won't be readable at that point at
all
so let's I'm actually gonna go into dev
tools for this because this is gonna be
I'm gonna want to mess with these
positions a bit so let me bring over
remove this over I don't know if it's
worth it for me to bring over dev tools
because I don't know that I can zoom in
enough pretty even to be readable
and actually I do have I have media
queries and stuff going on here too so
let's let's make this bigger first
because I I wanna we're gonna have to
shrink it down and then this hit several
media queries several breakpoints so
right now all I'm changing is that
background position X so I'm just
hitting the down arrow key on my
keyboard to change that background
position and I'm wondering like do I
shrink this so that the whole thing fits
or do I just leave it so that it's
really big like this and partially
blocked I don't really know I don't know
the answer to that right now I'm
wondering maybe I can we shrink it a bit
I think like the largeness of it has a
good impact even because even if it's
off the screen you can't see it it still
appears like it's law you know that part
of its obscured but you can still get
like this this size so I kind of like
that I don't know that that looks okay
for now oh I'm gonna copy over what I
did now and then that way you you'll be
able to see it so in depth in chrome dev
tools I made some of these adjustments
and so basically we just drop down the
the x position the Y position and then I
change the background size from 60 to 49
and this is 49 whew port width so the
the size of the background is actually
dependent on the width of the screen so
it's if ty gives a responsiveness so it
scales nicely so you can see like it's
obviously smaller at this point now
we're also hitting some media queries so
that's that's potentially
changing the size but I don't think
right there yeah that breakpoints not
changing the size it's just changing the
positioning all right see so we do have
some really weird stuff happening at
some points now that we'll need to work
out now I don't know that it will work
all that out on this video but just
basically and at this point we've hit
another breakpoint so I want to change
it because that's obviously not working
I don't want it to be up that high so
goodness that's yeah that starts to look
terrible when you get down lower we'll
have to figure something out but that's
okay so I'm gonna change this break
point so this 1200 pixel break point
instead of 26% through the background
position why I'm gonna change that to
negative 32 percent oops
and an easy fix that we might do so this
component actually doesn't display at
all once we get small enough screen so
we could instead of trying to mess with
all of this we could just make it go
away I mean this is depending on on how
it looks I think it does make sense that
probably at the point where the logos
gets centered at that point
this hero section should go away and so
that's nine hundred nine hundred or so
looks like 992 so we'll set this 992 and
this this media query controls when that
is displayed right so I didn't want for
users with small screens they're most
likely on a mobile device so when this I
didn't want them to one have to load a
large image here and have a huge section
to have to scroll down
Donna's section so let's see all right
that works we also have to adjust our
media query now for the nav component to
make it display at that that range I'm
gonna check the live chat again just
really quickly okay Ahmed says I'm gonna
probably already left so I don't know if
he'll hear this or not but he said he's
got to go cuz the time in India is 1243
a.m. so gotta get some sleep
totally understand that so I'll see you
hopefully next week I can get some
streams in at a decent quality from my
office thanks for watching I'm ed let's
see alright looks like there's some good
conversation going on in a live chat but
it doesn't look like a lot is directed
at me in terms of questions so okay it
looks like XD said the resolution is is
cool it's so cool Alberto says Umberto
likes how it looks partially blocked so
so this monitor so maybe we will
increase the size and just let it be a
little bit blocked I'm with you there I
think it you still get the sense that
it's large even though you can't see all
of it and since its I mean it's
basically a symmetrical thing so you can
you can get even if you've never seen
this is called a monstrous even if
you've never seen one before
you can basically guess that it's gonna
continue to be a circle I mean I don't I
have seen one before and I've seen this
whole image but it seems to me like the
shape of it you know suggests basically
that it keeps going around anyway so
I'll work on that a bit Sean that's what
I was creating cuz just came on
basically I'm I'm editing this this
section used to be really big like a big
hero section and we're shrinking it down
to make it much shorter and so we need
to make a lot of adjustments here with
the size of the image and the font size
and you know how they're they're
displayed their positioning
umberto says are you not using the hide
on materialized classes yeah so if
you've if you've been watching or you
might have noticed in the code I'm using
materialized as my framework for all my
styles and there are already classes to
hide and show things in materialized I
didn't use those classes before because
I had like custom breakpoints that I
wanted to use they didn't match up with
the breakpoints that were already built
in although at this point I probably
could switch to those because I think
our breakpoints are actually starting to
align so originally the breakpoints
weren't lined up but now I think like
this breakpoint here does match up with
the materialized breakpoints so that's
probably a good idea what would they be
hide on I think that would be hide on
medium and down let's do that
that's certainly at like a much cleaner
way to do it so I'm going to try this so
instead of having our showing and hiding
this in some CSS that we've written
we're gonna try to use the class hide on
medium and down so I think that's how it
goes if it doesn't work at all then I'll
look it up but I'm pretty sure that's
the the way you write it and then let's
take out so we won't need this actually
we will probably I'll leave this max
height thing in because they don't have
a height class built-in all right so let
me save that and this should still hide
oops that I start the video accidentally
started the video I keep doing that also
I might just take the video out while
I'm working so I quit accidentally
starting it alright so it should
disappear nice it did Umberto awesome
suggestion so now we're not gonna worry
about doing our breakpoints manually
we're gonna use the now that our
breakpoints are actually lining up with
the built-in ones for materialise we can
just use those classes so that's cool
let me let's see I'm gonna check the
lights out really quick questions
Isaiah sass how are you structuring your
code I think in CSS it's easy to have oh
no we're gonna code yeah for sure it is
and my CSS right now is so if you look
if you check out the repo and look at my
style does CSS file it's a mess it's
really like the reason that it's a mess
there's two reasons why is why it's a
mess so all this was originally built
and with sass and then just converted
over to CSS so this isn't really how I
wrote it you know this is the converted
version so it's a little bit messed up
because of that the other reason is I
had intended most of this to actually
live in the components so I didn't
bother trying to organize it that much
because I always figured well I'm just
going to move this over into all the
components at some point anyway I have
slowly been moving things over but I
haven't obviously I have not moved
everything over so at some point I'd
like to move it into the components but
it's just not happening yet actually if
anybody if you really want to get some I
don't know like some pull request
accepted on github just to like build up
your portfolio maybe really like want to
want it to look a little bit more
impressive for a job or something feel
free to take that on to even if it's you
just want to move a little bit over
that's cool as long as everything still
works I'll definitely accept that pull
request otherwise I might have saved
some of this I have a student worker
right now and I'm hopefully gonna have
some more student workers from the
computer science department this might
be a really good thing to just start
them out with so that they get used to
you know submitting pull requests and
just some basic stuff because they're
really knowledgeable about a lot of
computer science things but not really
about web development so kind of they
need to be brought in with like little
little steps so anyway I fully
acknowledge that my CSS is a mess right
now
and I ignores that that is not ideal XD
SD a-- media queries for all sizes not
really I don't I don't know I'd have to
look I didn't I don't think I'm using
that many media queries but maybe I am I
think as I was doing this I was trying
to go really fast like before launch so
I think I did get sloppy with my media
queries at some point so I probably do
have a lot of them more than I need
XD asks about CSS preprocessors yeah so
I did use sass but I'm not right now
Patrick says the the white bar at he's
asking about the white bar so basically
what happened is with that white bar is
so like you can see here you can kind of
see the nav here I have to adjust some
stuff so this actually shows up but the
navs there and then it disappears
because I have a media query to hide it
at this point I just need to adjust it
so when I adjusted the media query for
this section it made it disappear so
there's this like basically from this
wide to this wide there's the space now
where there's nothing here so I just
need to make the
a thinner version of the nav appear
there so when I go over to edit we're
about I'm about to edit that component
now so I'll change that in a second and
then that'll work actually says you can
you can split it man are you talking
about my CSS yeah
and use one style sheet for component
yeah yeah that was my that was my plan
that was my plan to do it so originally
this site was actually just a static
HTML site it was not react and that's
where the majority of the Styles were
made in sass for that site so that's why
it was just one style sheet like I said
the idea was to split it up when it
became a react site it just happens it
just hasn't happened as fast as I as I
wanted to could see
okay so XD Senate said a PR Senate PR
trying to change it all that stuff thank
you I appreciate that I'll check that
out after the video yeah okay so Joshua
says you need to add the SAS loader to
your web pack config yes so when I first
started working with next J s that
wasn't you couldn't do custom configs
for web pack so this was like I don't
know we're like almost on Version three
four next is something like that this
was like way back like pre version two
you couldn't do that so when I started
this project I would just assume that I
couldn't do it and then after I started
it I realized that you could now do
custom web pack configs but at that
point I had already like I was already
in the middle of it and I thought you
know what i don't i don't even care at
this point i'm just gonna keep going
with it but yeah you you can add the
sass loader in and next lets you do that
now and so it's definitely possible and
it would be better let's see yes XD is
laughing at me in the live chat here
because i have one file for all the
styles yeah i mean there are actually a
lot of styles within the components now
too so technically i have many files but
I only have one CSS file alright so the
only thing I think I really need to do
now before I move on to the nav
component is make sure that this text
doesn't overlap the logo and I just need
to make this text a lot smaller so I'm
gonna have going to dev tools on my
other screen here and then at least you
can see
yeah it needs to be I think like at
least that big it just looks way too
small otherwise so let's go with that
and move it down a bit
I tell you truth them I don't really
like how that looks right now I think
that looks bad yeah I mean look that's
that looks terrible
I don't know what do you think I think
that looks really bad Joshua asks about
next yes so that you made it sound
similar to create react react create at
yeah it is it's basically does the same
thing as that it just adds some other
things like mainly the biggest reason I
use next instead of the create react app
is server-side rendering because that
comes built in with next also the
routing is helpful I've learned how to
do routing with react router since then
but at first I didn't I wasn't that
great with routing in react so the fact
that next had built-in routing was also
a big plus alright so I we need to do
something with this I'm gonna bring up
I'm gonna bring up the live site as a
reference yeah something needs to happen
cuz this looks really unbalanced now so
I think we need maybe this needs to come
over a bit maybe be bigger there's just
so much space and I'm wondering Wyatt
why is this on three lines maybe I okay
so if you can see on the screen I have
it in this container so that's part of
the problem is a the container that it's
in is making it that small we might be
able to get away you'll see let me know
what you think about this but we could
probably get away with making this even
shorter and then having this line just
be like a line across the bottom here
I'm not sure I kind of I kind of want to
see how it would look I'm not a hundred
percent convinced that that would be the
right way to do it but I think it's
worth a shot
so to make that happen
I'm probably gonna have to change a
little bit of the HTML I mean I can I
can just mess with it here but if I
really wanted it to work I'll have to
change the structure a bit
yeah so that mean I was trying to just
change it in dev tools but there's too
much too much that needs change so you
can see how I have this now is I
actually have it inside like a column
class so so we have it in a row and then
in a column and we need to separate that
out so you can see like this is the
column which I've I've messed around
with in dev tools and then the row but
the row is really restricting it down to
this size so I can't go over so we need
to completely just take it out of the
row so we can position it however we
want so I do want to keep basically I
just need to keep this h1 so let's take
that out and then everything within this
row we'll get rid of and we'll just pop
this in here oh man Wow that that's
terrible
I mean we are whenever we save a
committed will reformat this anyway but
yes it's not a big deal
also we had the I'll see if this works
you might have to the text might revert
to being black yeah it looks like it did
so in the add the class
white text there we go okay so now we
have it to the point where we can at
least see their the only problem with
doing it this way is like at some point
we're gonna have to make even further
adjustments right because it's just too
big I mean maybe we could decrease the
font size a bit so that we wouldn't have
to worry so that would like would never
hit I mean we're close right now I just
never want there to be an overlap over
top of this image so need some
adjustment
at this point I'm thinking like I
probably could have just completely
redone this this whole section and not
just tried to adjust it but let's at
least you know do it do a little bit of
adjustment here just to get a good
visual of what what it could be and
let's make make this shorter
that's good for now and let's move this
down
okay
and I definitely want to move this over
okay all right so that'll give us like a
rough idea of where this potentially
could be so I will just look at this for
a second you all can check it out as
well let me know what you think I mean
basically we're going from from this
let's break them out so we can see the
side-by-side you know we've kind of made
it really I guess extreme change here
you know originally originally I wasn't
thinking would be that extreme
all right so the delay on the video
should be up so hopefully I'll be
getting some feedback
okay feedback is it is kind of weird
okay so I'm going back now in the live
chat and checking out some of the
feedback
okay so Matt says can make the the logo
in the upper left larger and vertically
Center it okay
Philip asked is that an image or text in
the center if you're talking about this
this is actually text so you'd ask that
a while ago so maybe maybe you figured
that uh there okay so Justin had said
you could make it make it one line okay
and that agrees one line we'd be better
Matt also says I have to admit I don't
like the reactant line styles are so
excited to move from inline styling to
CSS I can't believe we were moving back
to inline and popularity yeah I know it
is really weird it was really weird when
I saw it at first too because that's how
I don't know I mean I had everything
always said like don't use inline CSS
but the I I've I'm on board with it now
because of the cons just being having
everything being modular and reusable by
be if I can make my components so
self-contained to the point where I
could just pull one component off of one
project and pop it into another project
and it would look the same and behave
the same that is super valuable so I
really like that that aspect of it
especially if I could just with a few
things adjust the styles to match like
the new color scheme but basically
everything else would be able to say the
same
I think that's valuable and for me at
least that helped me to get over the
weirdness of it of putting the Styles
you know in line okay Matt says the the
logo in the upper left needs to have
size increase to match yellow to
elements in the scope it barely
registers on the screen with the other
elements that's exactly what everyone
was saying in the meeting yesterday so
that was the the whole point of
decreasing this stuff was so that this
and get lost so yeah you doubt you're
right on target that's what that was the
general consensus yesterday John says if
you use flex direction column div inside
your header within a flex div row you
would have much more responsive control
without playing with the margins etc
also the REM font size can tie well to
responsive with okay I will now when
when I am using the Flex stuff the how
back this support go for that I am using
flex in some other areas the site so I'm
not super concerned about the support
for it
but I do I have noticed that like ie 11
just when I use flex with ie 11 it
doesn't it doesn't look right so I don't
know as anyone has experience with that
I mean I'm not super worried about it
there's not that many people that that
even view the site with IE 11 but if I
if it's not too difficult to support it
I would like to support it so let's work
let me let me just see if I can make
this bigger since we've had a few
suggestions about making this bigger I
just want to see what it would look like
so let's make this a bit bigger Oh
actually yeah that doesn't look bad at
all I don't know what what size that is
originally but it looks good oh yeah
it's definitely big enough we can make
that bigger awesome
[Music]
okay so ie11 does have 98% support
that's cool and that was John John
Justin for me about that XD saying you
can use WebKit prefixes okay cool yeah
the main thing that I've noticed breaks
and ie11 is when I try to vertically
align things with flexbox maybe that's
like the one thing that's not supportive
but yeah actually that that logo looks a
lot better when it's bigger like that so
I'm like I'm gonna bring that over and
currently this the styles for that logo
currently live in the style dot CSS so
this is going to be an instance where we
can move that into the component so this
is going to be in the nav component and
it's fine it's the brand logo so we can
put it
oops not on the class I want to want an
inline style and then I definitely want
to remove this in the CSS so assuming
that this does look alright and let me
move I'm gonna get rid of this you'll
need that right now take it I keep
clicking this accidentally yeah that
looks good
let me do okay I I think that that looks
alright so let's go to we'll take a
little chunk out of this giant
unorganized CSS file here so it feels
really good every time I get to delete
something out of this file
so line 208 man we got I forgot I had
some media queries associated with it as
well
all right so I will have to include
these so let's grab this well I got a
lot of stuff I while we're here why
don't I just grab all the nav stuff and
then I can just get rid of it from this
file I didn't even realize I had this
much all right so
now that the formatting is insane like
it said this is not usually a live
format CSS this was just the Auto
formatting whoops I'm gonna move it to
our component Tim the nav component here
I'll leave that here just for now but
I'm gonna take that out and down below
it looks like I had already transferred
some stuff over here so we may have to
clean it up I want in case I've done
something here that I was overriding I'm
gonna put all the new styles on top so
that when it cascades it should still
all work and then I can always clean
that up if there's any duplicates so the
only thing that I need to change right
now is this height nope not that height
the logo height
so grande logo image Heights needs to be
130 and now I can remove this the reason
I didn't want to keep this here is
because this would override everything
in the media queries and I need that so
I'm gonna save that I guess I could
check quickly to make sure all right
well that's nothing nothing changed
significantly so that's cool that works
now let's remove all this stuff from the
style the styles that CSS
oh yes that felt so good to get rid of
that so to see you cutting down on her
here all right I'm gonna check back in
the live stack quickly okay John said
that his most recent site is all flex
and it with ie 11 it's good so maybe
maybe the maybe I need to just go back
and make sure that I do have the correct
vendor prefixes and things which as it
looks looks so complicated yet I know it
does I feel like every time I go back to
this file someone else comments about
how how messy it is but it's true it is
really messy it was never supposed to be
like that um sometimes you just have to
do things to get a site launched and
then you clean it up later that was the
case in case you haven't seen like the
whole thing and the story of this site
quick recap is this was a totally
unexpected project that I got assigned
to like one day I was working on
something and all of a sudden it was
like drop everything do this project and
the completion date was like it was just
a really really tight deadline and so a
lot a lot of the stuff some of the stuff
that's not really a great practice in
the code is entirely possible that it's
just because of my lack of knowledge of
the right way to do it but some of the
stuff CSS included was simply because I
just it just needed to get done so it
was like you know what I need this done
like I'm just gonna type it out and I'll
have time later so there were a lot of
points where it was like I'll have time
later to clean this up
and now is really that
later so so that's why I'm doing it now
although I do appreciate everybody
saying that I should clean it up so I'm
not I'm not mad about it but I'm just
saying I I agree you don't have to
convince me that it should be cleaned up
all right so what else did we want to
change in here not a hero we wanted to
make that the branding text bigger where
is that I think it's here okay yeah it's
here so if you're not sure this out link
this is from a few a few streams ago we
made a component that basically fixed a
bug in react GA that let us do click
tracking with outbound links and open
them up in a new tab so that's why this
is the out link component so you can
check out that that video and and the
code for that if you're interested but
that's why it's not just your regular
link tag so for this I think I will just
do this in dev tools first just to get
an idea what its gonna look like do I
not have I actually don't think I even
have a font size set for this this is
just the default font size interesting
all right so let's see this is up from
it's just a a bit bigger 18 it's 18
pixels
Strega 20 20 doesn't look too bad I do
think it needs a bit more room at the
top I mean it's not bad I don't want to
I don't want this to be overwhelming so
I think if we just move it down a bit
bump it up to 20 pixels I think that'll
work especially since this this is
smaller now we'll probably go a bit
smaller with that font i think that's
decent so let me find that I've given
this a class of fus branding so we'll
just move this I did change this to 16
and we'll add the indentation step is
crazy I need I had a package for Adam
that was Auto indenting everything for
me and it was awesome but it was messing
up the who were using prettier and then
so it was messing up stuff with prettier
so that basically like it was changing
the positioning in all my files and it
would look like I had something to
commit to get when all that had happened
is my Adam plug-in had changed the
formatting from what prettier had made
it and it just kept flipping back and
forth so I disabled it but now my my
auto indenting is gone so I have to sort
that out
all right you hear that that was my I
have an 8 month old and that was her in
the background yelling yelling for me
okay let's make this a bit smaller this
is starting I mean this is getting to
the point where I think it's close
also there's just like there's a little
weirdness of I've gotten used to be so
used to the other one anything I do now
is gonna look weird at first to me so
once I get over that I think I'll be
able to look at this a bit more
objectively and see whether or not it's
it works but I think that maybe just a
bit smaller on that size and then maybe
move it down a little
yeah and I think that'll work
[Music]
okay yeah it's not too bad let me know
what you think in the live chat if you
haven't already Oh awesome Patrick just
said in the live chat they have a
prettier atom plug-in that's great Oh
Austin check that out
Oh aim high joined us hey how's it going
aim high so I just followed you on
Twitter awesome so I yeah I'll
definitely I'll check that out in I
think the last stream or one of our
recent streams aim high said like told
us about a job a new job so did you
start yet or were you starting I can't
remember if you said when you were gonna
start or not if you did start how is it
alright Umberto's says it almost seems
like there needs to be something in the
space to the right of the brand to
balance out the slogan but it might be
weird yeah I'm with you like it just it
does look a little weird maybe if I move
this and make it bigger it'll balance a
bit yeah let me try that let me make
sure I bring over the changes that I
made
let's see
okay am I was gonna start on Monday the
third all right well good luck I hope
everything is it's awesome at your new
job super excited about that
Isaiah sighs why is it better to convert
the website to react yes so while I'm
adjusting the size here I'll talk a
little bit about that reacts so react
has a lot of advantages in this case for
me converting it from a static site to
react meant that it was going to be a
lot easier for me to import the data so
on a static if so I wanted to import the
data from from WordPress that was the
plan all along the static site was like
a back-up plan to say okay well there's
the deadlines really tight it's way
faster for me to just code all this out
then to either try to make a wordpress
theme or make the react site that I
eventually wanted to so that was just
kind of the back-up plan that I know I
could get this out but the problem with
that is if you wanted to update that
static site I had to go in and update it
in the code there are people there are
like student workers who work for the
catechetical Institute that need to be
able to update it and they don't have
any experience with code so I need the
the content needed to come from a
content management system so with react
I can easily build a component and those
components can then I can render all the
data into those components specifically
when I'm using next JS I can pull in the
data and render its server-side so then
it's great for search engine
optimization if I were to just like try
to turn my static site and like do some
custom you know JavaScript templates for
that and pull that in client-side I
would have no
search engine optimization and just so
for me specifically those are a big deal
but this in general react is really a
nice way to do things especially if you
need like if you need things to happen
on your site where there's going to be
changes to the Dom instead of doing it
all with jQuery which is what people I
guess would normally do react has a
different way of doing things and it
keeps like this alternate version of the
Dom and it compares the two to only
change things that need change instead
of rerender everything so you end up
getting better performance when things
change on your site the other things too
like it does client-side routing you
know nicely so you notice like you click
around on this site there's not page
refreshes so there's just so many cool
things that react us really well and
it's not that you couldn't do it like
it's not that I couldn't have done all
that stuff with a static site but it
would have been really complicated for
me to do it on my own and then try and
for somebody else to try to keep up with
that would have been insane like you
know if I made my own custom routing
solution and all that and and I probably
would have done it given the time frame
I would have used jQuery so it would
have been very hard to maintain I'm sure
there's other benefits to react to that
I'm just I'm forgetting or that I don't
know about but I can't find in dev tools
this background there we go finally so
let's move this in a bit and make it
bigger
and then just move it back over a bit
now I'm just thinking if we do it like
this upright bring that down
I was hoping that that would make it
seem like they're I mean it's definitely
not as much space there but it still
doesn't exactly look right to be honest
with you if I could just lose the tag
line I think it would look fine but I
can't like there's no way they'll let me
take the tag line out I would actually
love to get rid of the tag line because
then I wouldn't have to import this font
which I only import for this tag line if
anyone can think of a better place to
put this tag line that still appears
near the top let me know because that
that I think is really what's causing
the issue for us right now is that this
is just kind of like odd
so I am gonna save the few things that I
did here and definitely need to think
about that tagline some more so I'm
probably gonna wrap up the video soon
definitely significant change here but
I'm to a point now where I think I
really just need to think about I don't
know about you but I get like I like to
mess around like this but at some point
like I just need to close my eyes and
like picture what this is gonna look
like and sometimes I actually just like
jot it use a pen and paper and jot it
down and sometimes that's better than
just continuing to make adjustments and
I think I'm getting to that point where
I need to just kind of visualize what
this could be I don't think it's not
terrible but I don't you know this is
the home page just first thing people
are gonna see I want it to look really
really good and this just to me does not
look really good so so I'm gonna finish
up with the actual like CSS changes here
I'm gonna go back to the live chat I'm
gonna go through and try to answer all
the questions I can so if you have a
question throw it in there now and then
I'm gonna just I'm gonna wrap it up I
know I said the beginning I didn't want
this to be a super long video and it has
ended up being a pretty long video I
really I just kind of didn't want to
have this giant video that was of little
low quality but I guess too late for
that so I'm gonna I'm gonna scroll back
up to the top of the live chat now and
I'll tell you the the chat has gone on
long enough that I have missed out on
some of the stuff that was at the very
top so I don't think I missed out on too
much but just in case if I do miss your
question throw it in the comments or
mess up me on Twitter okay say hi
someone said in Grinnell says to look
from India
hey how's it going let's see
well someone says it was 1:35 a.m. where
they were at and that was at the start
of the video so thanks thanks for
watching so late
okay so I'm still scanning through I did
stop quite a few times and go through
live chats I have answered a lot of
these already but I'm just looking for
for something that I missed
or maybe just didn't answer as fully as
I could have also yeah if you don't if
you don't care for the Q&A session and
you just hear freaking the CSS stuff
thanks so much for watching I'll be back
I will be back next week if you want to
join in usually around 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Time Monday and Tuesday I will not be
streaming Monday I will be at a wedding
my boss is getting married so I'll be at
his wedding and then Tuesday is a
holiday here in the US so I won't be
working I'll be at a picnic at my
grandfather's house so for everybody in
the u.s. happy fourth of July
for that day so I'll be back on
Wednesday though assuming I don't have
some weird some meeting that time and if
so then I'll just change that in normal
time and I'll send out a message on
Twitter I'm scrolling and I'm still not
seeing anything that I didn't address
yet so I guess I did a decent job of
watching the live chat this time see I
thought I saw something but it wasn't
directed to me
[Music]
okay here's the question I missed so
chef Shawshank
sheshank Mishra says hey Jessie I just
started with JavaScript which back in
language should I learn it with I this
this was asked a while ago so hopefully
you're still tuning in but just for
anybody else that might have a similar
question as well if you're learning
JavaScript you don't nut you don't
actually need to learn a back-end
language with JavaScript because you
could use JavaScript on the server side
as well so you could use motor it
depends on what you want to do though so
like for instance if let's say you
wanted to work with WordPress then learn
PHP do you want to work with Microsoft
stuff like dotnet framework then learn
learn c-sharp do you want to develop I
mean I get do you want to end up
developing for for mobile you know for
Android Java or X what's the new thing
now like it's called Kotlin so you might
want one of those but then again you
could always just use react native and
then just learn JavaScript so depending
on what you want to do the answer is
gonna be different but if you don't have
anything in particular in mind
I personally would just stick with
JavaScript learn that really well and
learn server-side to learn node and then
you'll be good you can build entire
applications just with JavaScript but
otherwise I mean if you have the time
and you want to learn something then
then just you know figure out what you
want to do and then pick the backend
language based on that Dimitri says
great videos helps a lot thanks Jesse
awesome thank you for saying that
I appreciate you watching too
Joshua says what do you like to use for
accepting credit card payments with
react actually I've never done an
e-commerce site with react
I have done a couple that we're just
like straight up WordPress sites I've
used I think I've used stripe obviously
PayPal everybody's used PayPal before
and I use authorized.net so this is I
think the three that I've worked with of
the three the hardest to work was
probably authorized.net stripe is super
simple to work with PayPal is pretty
simple as well so it might just come
down to the rates really or if you're
doing it because and this of course like
I said I haven't done it with react so I
don't know if any of those would be
harder to work with and react but at
least for what I had to do with them in
WordPress which to be honest was mostly
plug-in based so it's not like I was
hard coding like PHP or anything so
but I found stripe and PayPal to be the
easiest and this was part this was a few
years ago the last time I had to do any
commerce site so just keep that in mind
when you consider my answer and Ahmed
said okay I'll med was having it it's
like a side discussion with someone else
so I'll skip that hello James wait like
an hour ago James said that's what's
happening actually I think I did see
that I think I I addressed that question
so for a second I felt really bad cuz
James James says hey I'm a noob here
what's happening so I really really
especially like to answer people who are
new answer the questions so that you
know they could welcome right off the
bat XD said we have a nerds meeting here
I didn't see that the first time but
okay it looks like there's a decent
conversation going on about react native
so the video is already really long I'm
not gonna read everything out but that
was awesome if if you if you're watching
the recording and you haven't got a
chance to join in live I definitely like
recommend it if if you ever get a chance
cuz there's so many very knowledgeable
people in the live chat that provides so
much help if you ask a question they're
just really great it was kind of a nice
little community that's developed in the
live chat and they're they're super
helpful and and super nice so join in if
you can Joshua asks have you had any
success with stripe and react okay this
is so as I said earlier I have not done
any e-commerce with reacts not yet
okay Patrick asks what NPM module lets
you use class instead of class name let
me let me check really quick because
what is that I brought up contributors I
know it was in a was it Dan I think it
was Danny that contributed that let me
see I was hoping it would link right to
that here
can I see it here I guess not
I guess I just checked my package.json I
don't remember offhand but I'm sure if I
see it all all remember right away so
let's check in here oh here we go
babble plug-in react HTML attribute to
attrs so I don't you can see that one
that's the one and then I think there
was some configuration maybe in this
babble or see yeah so I had to add this
in and confess well I didn't add this in
Patrick added I'm pretty sure not
Patrick Danny added this in I'm pretty
sure that was the pull request from from
Danny so anyway but it's really helpful
so thanks for that
that pull request and that's the that's
the module and I'm pretty sure it does
work it's not just for class it's for
the other the other attributes as well
so I'm gonna get spoiled by it and then
work on a project where I don't have it
and then mess it up but it's really cool
for now
[Music]
okay cool it looks like pretty much
everybody was saying that the resolution
was fine so that's good to know
maybe I finally get the right settings
here and I can actually stream from home
so I'll do I'm gonna check out the video
later on and and play it back and just
kind of see what the quality was but if
it's decent then maybe I am I will be
able to stream from home so oh that's
really good because then it doesn't
really matter the only thing that was
bothering me about not being able to go
in to work to do my work was just not
being able to stream so if I can do it
from home then then IT can take their
time and blood github for as long as
they want and I'll enjoy working from
home
[Music]
someone whose I can't read this name
because it's it's not in like nor my
normal alphabet it says says what the
hell in here
so I was not sure you know what I bet
that this person joined in right when I
had my style.css file open so that was
the appropriate response
it looks like I'm seeing like a few
different comments of just kind of
adjusting things so I'm gonna say I'm
gonna look over that later when I finish
up these adjustments but I'm gonna skip
over for now so I can make sure I get to
everybody's questions
[Music]
haha man I'm oh I was just getting
hammered today with all the comments I'm
never showing my style dot CSS file on a
stream again this is like Patrick says
I've never seen a mini map with a
scrollbar before so I'm just messing on
you guys you're fine
like I can take it and I agree with you
[Music]
XD says I prefer to be refactoring while
coding so yeah this was in response I
think when I was talking about saying I
just kept putting off actually you know
organizing everything the way it should
be I I really do too like I like to
refactor like immediately after I get it
working and everything and then refactor
but these are all all things that are
best practices that you get you are
mentioning and so I did not follow those
for this project okay so some people
were asking about the oh let me go back
to here this image so it's actually this
is called a monstrance so mo NS TR ance
a monstrance so i guess it sounded like
I was saying monsters so yeah so it's
actually a monstrance I had a few
questions about that in the live chat so
this is in the middle here is what's
called the Eucharist so I mean this is
like in terms of Catholicism this is
like the most important thing about like
the entire worship like have you ever
been to a Catholic like worship ceremony
it's called a mass and this is like the
highlight so anyway I mean I don't I
don't to go into a big discussion here
because this is a coding thing but
basically just know that these
monstrance --is are supposed to be like
very beautiful because it holds
something very important so
that's what this is a picture of so in
terms of the catechetical Institute
their audience for this are going to be
people who work within the Catholic
Church so they're gonna like immediately
when they see this it's going to be a
very powerful image for them so that's
why we wanted to include it right here
and it was important but yes but it's
not it's not monster
it is a monstrance and to be honest with
you the word just probably came from
Latin and I know quite a bit of Latin
but I right now I can't tell you what
that word originally came from but
anyway let's see okay so we have some
comments about the the tagline and
things so okay so we're asking about
like potentially could we make this
smaller and then put this tag line under
it and actually I was kind of thinking
about that but do I think that we want
to keep it bigger but it may if I can't
think of anything else that maybe
something we go to is to just have this
as a very small kind of image in the top
and have this under what off to try it
out but I'm pretty sure that this looks
better when it's bigger but we'll see
there's definitely room for kind of you
know messing around with it I guess I'll
Allen says bless you so I don't know I
guess that was directed to me so thank
you I say it says how do you come up
with designs for your website basically
so I start off everything the basis for
all the designs are is material design
so
whose design framework is called
material design if you haven't checked
it out just type it into a Google search
the first thing that comes up most
likely will be Google's documentation on
material design really nice I really
like it the more I get the more I learn
about it get into it the more I
appreciate it so that's the basis for my
design
I'd like I like it because it's a pretty
standard thing it's used for a lot of
sites so from a user's perspective the
design patterns will be familiar the way
the UI works will be familiar so I like
that if a user comes to one of my sites
they'll see things that they most likely
seen on other sites or apps so just I
don't know I think it just makes things
a little more comfortable for the user
for me it gives me the benefit of not
having to make every single decision
about the design so I start from there
and then I adapt based on what the needs
are so you know whatever whatever the
client or whoever from that I'm working
with whatever they need sometimes I do
have to adapt things to accommodate that
or sometimes they have very distinct
like preferences for style that I try to
blend as best I can with material design
principles so not every single thing on
the site will follow material design
spec exactly because occasionally I I
need to kind of be a little bit flexible
to be able to try to blend the style
that the client wants with that but for
the most part I do try to follow
material design styles and then when I'm
actually thinking about design stuff
sometimes like I just throw it on there
and just move it around and see how it
works I like to draw things out on paper
I'm a terrible terrible artist when it
comes to drawing but I can at least get
like a visual of where things are laid
out so I wouldn't consider myself a
designer but I do have to do design work
so that's kind of like my my process for
for design and it's it's I've never
undergone any like formal training for
design or anything so I'm sure that
there are more efficient ways of doing
that but this is just what I've kind of
developed out of necessity of having to
do this
Oh
[Music]
Sudan sue I'm not sure how to pronounce
that sorry if I've mispronounced your
name ask can you please suggest some
tutorial for Python and Django I don't
know about Django
but for Python Udacity intro to CSS
course is done and all in Python and I
like that course so that might be
something that you might want to check
into and then supplement that with
something that's more Django specific as
well Alexandra says hello
hey how's it going matt says the Django
website actually has a really good intro
tutorial
jay-j 5:03 cool says it kind of looks
like an old-school wordpress design
honestly I'm not gonna lie the header to
me especially when I've shrunk it like
this does look more old school than so
like that the header as it currently is
this does not look like an old school
design but this is starting to look more
like an old school design I didn't
realize it until you said it but as soon
as I saw that comment I totally agree
and now I feel terrible about it
I guess yeah no I I like it so much less
now that you said that we'll see maybe
I'll have to think about it even more
but I mean at the end of the day like I
am I just need to include these out
basically every element that's in here
right now has to be in there somewhere
so I have to include them all I can do
some rearranging of things but as long
as they're all in there it should be
okay so I guess I have some room if
anyone has any other suggestions
as long as everything's included it
might actually work so let me know
but yeah I've to think about that this
ended up being more difficult than I'd
anticipated hopefully the end result is
worth it though I might do an alternate
version where the change is less drastic
where maybe I just shrink everything
slightly if I can't get this one to work
and then maybe it'll work it'll work
better like that but anyway I I think
that's it for today
and yeah we've definitely dropped below
our normal amount of viewers at this
point so thank you for watching and I
will I won't be back for a while so next
Wednesday will probably be the next time
I do a stream so have a great weekend
everyone and if your than in the United
States have a great holiday next week
and let me know if you have any
questions I'm available to answer
anything on Twitter or any other social
media stuff and thank you so much for
for watching today